WE HAVE A LOT OF NEWS TO COVER
TONIGHT.
WE BEGIN WITH THIS FOX NEWS
ALERT.
MAJOR BREAKING NEWS SURROUNDING
THE POLITICIZATION OF THE FBI
WHISTLE BLOWERS NOW FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST THE BIAS IN THEIR
OWN RANKS ACCORDING TO A NEW
BOMBSHELL REPORT FROM THE
WASHINGTON TYPES TOP FBI AGENT
TIM TEBOW, YEAH, LIKE THE
QUARTERBACK, WAS REPORTEDLY
ESCORTED OUT OF THE WASHINGTON
FIELD OFFICE ON FRIDAY BUT TWO
OR THREE OTHER AGENTS, THEY TOOK
HIM OUT.
HE'S NOW ACCUSED OF, QUOTE,
POLITICAL BIAS IN HANDLING THE
INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER BIDEN'S
COMPUTER LAPTOP.
NOW THIS IS THE HIGH RANKING
AGENT WHO ALLEGEDLY ATTEMPTED TO
SLOW WALT THE HUNTER PROBE IN
2020.
NOW TONIGHT FOX NEWS HAS
CONFIRMED THAT TEBOW IS NO
LONGER WITH THE BUREAU.
WE DID REACH OUT TO THE FBI FOR
A STATEMENT.
THEY DECLINED TO COMMENT.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE'S
SPEAKING OUT BLASTING THE BIAS
AND ABUSE OF THE FBI.
QUOTE, TONIGHT SADLY WE HAVE
SEEN THIS BEFORE, FORMER TOP
AGENT, BY THE WAY, PETER STRZOK
WAS ALSO ONCE ESCORTED OUT OF
THE FBI BUREAU.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER FOR POLITICAL
BIAS.
REMEMBER PRIOR TO THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION?
HE TEXTED HIS COLLEAGUE, HIS
LOVER LISA PAGE, SAID HE HAD A
PLAN TO STOP TRUMP FROM EVER
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
WE'LL STOP HIM.
HE ALSO TEXTED ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY IF HER POLICY,
THAT THEY DISCUSSED IN ANDY'S
OFFICE, DIDN'T WORK.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE RUSSIA HOAX
TO SMEAR, SLANDER BESMIRCH
DONALD TRUMP IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT THAT HE DOES BECOME
PRESIDENT, FIRST, OF COURSE, TO
PREVENT HIM FROM EVER BECOMING
PRESIDENT.
AFTER HE WAS FIRED FROM THE
BUREAU, STRZOK WAS REWARDED WITH
A LUCRATIVE BOOK DEAL AND
NUMEROUS APPEARANCES ON FAKE
NEWS CNN, MSDNC WHERE FAR LEFT
POLITICAL BIAS IS REVERED AND
ADMIRED AND THE ANTI TRUMP WITCH
HUNTS AT THE FBI NEVER STOP.
DIRECTOR WRAY FAILED THIS
COUNTRY, AND THIS BRINGS US TO
THE MAR-A-LAGO RAID.
DESPITE HEAVY REDACTIONS FROM
THE DOJ IN THE AFFIDAVIT, WE CAN
NOW SEE THAT THE FBI RELIED ON
SPECULATIVE NEWS ARTICLES TO
JUSTIFY THEIR RAID.
THIS IS INSANITY.
THIS IS WHAT THE FBI HAS NOW
BEEN REDUCED TO, QUOTING
AMERICA'S ABUSEIVELY CORRUPT AND
BIASSED NEWS MEDIA?
AND REMEMBER, WHICH WAS A RAID
IN SEARCH OF DOCUMENTS REQUESTED
BY BUREAUCRATS AT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AS THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL PUT IT, QUOTE, THE
MAR-A-LAGO AFFIDAVIT, THAT'S ALL
THERE IS?
THE REDACTED 38 PAGES, ADD TO
THE EVIDENCE THAT THE FBI'S
SEARCH WAS REALLY ALL ABOUT A
DISPUTE OVER DOCUMENTS?
AND LATE LAST WEEK, RETIRED
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
KEVIN BROCK HAD THIS TO SAY.
LISTEN CLOSELY.
>> THE FBI SHOULD NOT HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS, TO YOUR EARLIER POINT,
WAS INITIATED BY THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES, WAS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE SETTLED ALONG
ESTABLISHED ROUTES IN THAT
REGARD, YOU KNOW, TRADITIONALLY
USED.
THERE WAS NO NEED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT IN THIS
AND THERE WAS CERTAINLY NO NEED
FOR AN INVASIVE SEARCH OF THE
RESIDENCE.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO REGRET
THIS.
YOU KNOW, MANY PEOPLE EVEN ON
THE LEFT SAID, IF THERE'S NO
SMOKING GUN, IF THERE'S NO REAL
MEATY VIOLATION HERE, THIS IS
NOT GOING TO GO WELL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Sean: IN AN OP-ED BROCK
DECLARED THE DOJ HAS NO CASE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NOW
WE'RE LEARNING THE FBI, QUOTE,
ACCIDENTALLY SEIZED PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENTS FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
HOME DURING THEIR FISHING
EXPEDITION INCLUDING
ATTORNEY/CLIENT MATERIAL THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS PROHIBITED
FROM EVER VIEWING.
EVER.
IN OTHER WORDS A VERY CLEAR
VIOLATION OF THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT.
THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T HAVE BROAD
SWEEPING WARRANTS LIKE THIS ONE
SIGNED OFF BY A MAGISTRATE THAT
HATES TRUMP, LOVES OBAMA AND
ALREADY ONCE RECUSED HIMSELF
FROM A CASE INVOLVING DONALD
TRUMP.
BUT THE DOJ, THE FBI, THEY DON'T
WANT A SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW
THIS CASE AS REQUESTED BY
TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS.
INSTEAD THEY SIMPLY WANT US TO
TRUST THEM.
THEY ALREADY READ IT ALL ANYWAY,
THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH TIME
INCLUDING MATERIAL OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S THAT WAS ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
THIS IS THE SAME ORGANIZATION,
THE SAME FBI THAT BROUGHT YOU,
LET'S SEE, ANDREW McCABE AND JIM
COMEY, PETER STRZOK, LISA PAIGE,
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX, THE
MUELLER WITCH HUNT, THE PHIZER
COURT FRAUD AND LIES TO THE FISA
COURTS, PREDAWN RAIDS WITH GUNS
DRAWN, 30 PEOPLE AT A TIME, FAKE
NEWS CNN CAMERAS AT ROGER
STONE'S RAID THEN THE PAUL
MANAFORT RAID THEN OTHER TRUMP
ASSOCIATES.
THE SAME ORGANIZATION THAT LET
HILLARY CLINTON OFF THE HOOK FOR
MISHANDLING A TON OF TOP SECRET
AND CLASSIFIED MATERIALS ON AN
UNSECURED PRIVATE SERVER,
MULTIPLE SERVERS ACTUALLY.
BECAUSE, ACCORDING TO COMEY, NO
REASONABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD
BRING A CASE.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WOULD LET
HER GET AWAY WITH OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE DELETING 30,000 E-MAILS
ACID WASHING HER HARD DRIVE WITH
BLEACH BIT AND DESTROYING ANY
DEVICES THAT MIGHT HAVE THOSE
E-MAILS WITH HAMMERS AND
REMOVING SUM CARDS TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DID NOT FINDEST SECRETARY
CLINTON OR HER COLLEAGUES
INTENDED TO, THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT THEY WERE EXTREMELY
CARELESS IN THEIR HANDLING OF
VERY SENSITIVE HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
STATUTES REGARDING THE HANDLING
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, OUR
JUDGMENT IS THAT NO REASONABLE
PROSECUTOR WOULD BRING SUCH A
CASE.
>> Sean: OH.
LAW'S BEEN BROKEN BUT NO
PROSECUTOR WOULD CHARGE HER.
THE ORGANIZATION THAT LET
HILLARY OFF THE HOOK IS NOW THE
VERY SAME ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
BEEN JUMPING THROUGH HOOPS TO
PROTECT A ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER
BIDEN AND BY HIS FATHER, WHO IS
IMPLICATED IN THAT LAPTOP FROM
HELL NUMEROUS TIMES WITH
EVIDENCE, IN FACT, THAT JOE
BIDEN, YOUR PRESIDENT, KNEW
EVERYTHING ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS, AND
THIS IS THE SAME ORGANIZATION
THAT ASKED FACEBOOK, WE DIDN'T
KNOW THIS UNTIL, WELL,
ZUCKERBERG JUST TOLD US TO TRUST
THEM BEFORE THE ELECTION IN
2020.
WATCH THIS.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF ATTENTION
ON TWITTER DURING THE ELECTION
BECAUSE OF THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY.
THE NEW YORK POST.
>> WE HAD THAT, TOO.
>> SO YOU GUYS CENSORED THAT AS
WELL.
>> SO WE TOOK A DIFFERENT PATH
THAN TWITTER.
BASICALLY, THE BACKGROUND HERE
IS THE FBI, I THINK, BASICALLY
CAME TO US, SOME FOLKS ON OUR
TEAM AND WAS LIKE, HEY, JUST SO
YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SHOULD BE ON
HIGH ALERT, WE THOUGHT THAT
THERE WAS A LOT OF RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA IN THE 2016 ELECTION,
WE HAVE IT ON NOTICE THAT
BASICALLY THERE'S ABOUT TO BE
SOME KIND OF DUMP OF -- THAT'S
SIMILAR TO THAT, SO JUST BE
VIGILANT.
>> Sean: BE VIGILANT.
DON'T GO WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
STORY THREE WEEKS BEFORE A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND DON'T
ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE, BECAUSE
IT MIGHT INFLUENCE PEOPLE'S
VOTING.
THE VERY REAL HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP WAS NOT RUSSIA
PROPAGANDA.
NOT AT ALL.
TRUMP HATING OFFICIALS AT THE
BUREAU WERE LYING TO PROTECT JOE
BIDEN SO THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD
BE DEFEATED.
AND OF COURSE BIG TECH AND THE
MEDIA MOB ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COMPLY.
THIS IS BEYOND AN EGREGIOUS AND
BLATANT ABUSE OF POWER ON SO
MANY LEVELS.
EVEN LATE NIGHT LIBERAL BILL
MAHER CAN SEE THE OBVIOUS TRUTH
OF WHAT THEY DID HERE AND
ACTUALLY SAID HIT WEEKEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
>> WHAT IS THE QUESTION?
>> WAS IT APPROPRIATE -- THE
QUESTION IS WAS IT APPROPRIATE
TO BURY THE HUNTER BIDEN --
>> YOU TALKING ABOUT THE PRESS
DOING THAT.
>> HE'S SAYING THAT'S WHAT THEY
DID AND THAT IS WHAT THEY DID.
THEY BURIED THE HUNTER BIDEN
STORY BEFORE THE ELECTION
BECAUSE THEY WERE LIKE WE CAN'T
RISK HAVING THE ELECTION THROWN
TO TRUMP WE'LL TELL THEM AFTER
THE ELECTION.
>> AND WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> I'M SAYING YOU KNOW FOR A
FACT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY DID.
>> I KNOW BECAUSE YOU ONLY WATCH
MSNBC.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> WELL THEN YOU WOULD KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: HE SAYS HE WATCHES FOX
NEWS BUT HE'S STILL A MEAT HEAD.
THIS IS WHY DIRECTOR WRAY HAS
DONE A GRAVE DISSERVICE TO WHAT
SHOULD BE THE PREMIER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
HE SHOULD HAVE CLEANED IT UP, HE
DIDN'T.
AND GETTING AWAY WITH EVERYTHING
HAS NOW LED TO MORE POLITICS AT
THE FBI.
HE NEEDS TO BE REPLACED.
AND, BY THE WAY, SO SHOULD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
NOW BILL MAHER AND I DON'T AGREE
WITH MUCH BUT HE'S AT LEAST
HONEST GIVE HIM CREDIT.
ACCORDING TO ONE BOWL ONE IN SIX
AMERICANS WOULD NOT HAVE VOTED
FOR JOE BIDEN HAD THEY KNOWN THE
LAPTOP SCANDAL WAS REAL.
ONE IN SIX, THAT'S IT GAME OVER
TRUMP WON 2020 WITH THOSE
NUMBERS.
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA, THEY
DON'T CARE.
SO MANY ON THE LEFT HAVE
LITERALLY SHUNNED LOGIC, ALL
TRUTH.
THEY DON'T CARE IF IN 2016 THEY
LIE ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN, THEY SPREAD IT AS
THOUGH IT'S GOSPEL TRUTH.
THEN WHEN YOU REALLY HAVE LAPTOP
WITH INFORMATION THAT IS DAMNING
TO A DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE, OH,
THAT'S RUSSIA DISINFORMATION
WHEN IN FACT IT WAS ANYTHING
BUT.
AND THEY DO THAT TO MA LINE
DONALD TRUMP AND ANYONE THAT
SUPPORTS HIM.
AND MANY, BY THE WAY, STILL
BELIEVE THAT THEIR VERY OWN LIE
WAS THE RUSSIA HOAX, THAT IT WAS
NOT A HOAX AT ALL.
MANY HAVE NO IDEA THAT JOE AND
HUNTER SOLD ACCESS TO OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO CHINA, TO
RUSSIA, TO UKRAINE, TO OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT, BY THE WAY, ARE
HOSTILE REGIMES THAT DON'T LIKE
OUR COUNTRY AND DON'T SEEM TO
CARE AT ALL ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
CORRUPTION.
FOR THEM, IT'S A MEANS TO AN
END.
DESTROY TRUMP AT ALL COSTS.
RIGHT ON CUE AT MSDNC, A PUNDIT
WHO CLAIMED THE HUNTER BIDEN LAP
TON WAS RUSS